doubt that we have done this is long
when we do this see my brethren in the
flesh before we get it up we got a show
together to talk about you know what I
mean so let's get into these topics
we've got God of War Ragnarok and yeah
it was funny
you thought you had me
New York
if you had me
Idols Montreal yeah the former yeah and
[Music]
um
yeah that PlayStation VR 2 though yeah
uh we're talking about uh the Studios
from the square units what's going to
happen then exactly before we get
started we got introduced The Four
Horsemen United in the realm my goals
because
the difficult game conqueror Lord of his
whole world and the how of the young
wolf my man Lord acting New York City
for his first time let's go
because uh my place don't look like this
video
and the hustle was hard so how was that
meet yesterday pause
yeah there's definitely not places like
that where I'm from don't doubts out to
everybody that pulled up and all that
and of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo players with a
single player selfish experience and
also
disastradamus the Lord of clarity and
Lord patreon of the iron bank my man
Lord solving that we do this I'm good
to have us all together is crazy there's
been how many years four or five years
we've never done a podcast just the four
of us but we've been in the room
together all together but there's other
people in the room whatever and again
that's all love that's all fair but this
is never happening so where to happen
it's great addict in New York City
getting the NYC experience to those of
you we have legs yeah
[Applause]
like most New York but
one game that I've been playing I've
been playing it for a while but I
haven't mentioned it so much
vampire survive oh
heard about that just imagine a man it's
like a forever Runner right in the style
of Castlevania right in old castle band
like old 8-bit Castlevania and basically
you have four characters you can pick
for them you only have one unlocked to
start the game and basically it starts
you out in the field and you're running
away from all these monsters coming at
you you don't do anything but move
around now what happens is you start off
with one ability right each character
has that one ability you have to try to
kill as many of the the Swarms coming at
you that's possible as you kill people
it you can you power up your XP right
you get XP and it brings your level up
as you bring your level up you're able
to unlock more Powers so what happens is
that as you're you're trying to
basically your running back always
looking for daylight and you're just
trying to not get caught get caught yeah
so the more powerful you get the more
people you kill the more XP you collect
the more powerful you get and all of a
sudden now you have four or five
different things going off at once to
protect you from these forms that are
increasingly crazy coming at you it is
the simplest form of dopamine hit you've
ever seen and it's been it people were
talking about it all year really
listen to me oh yes it was in Game Pass
it was a Game Pass PC preview for a bit
and that's what kind of went there
we go here we go
definitely doing things I can't wait for
people to start talking about it we
haven't played it yet once I think it's
on Game Pass this coming week right I
know we're gonna we have Summerville to
talk about so wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait so you
said it was on PC game pass it was on
peace and it's coming to regular game
pass this week yesterday
so you have that game pass ultimate
all right all right
I agree
and it's the simplest game you play my
phone probably
when you stop playing it and you look up
it's five hours later you're like what I
do what you do yeah bro and of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
access gay bro the prophet of Xbox
little swabby at see because right now
I'm a little bit above a Swami though
I'm like you're 99 I'm full Goku in a
second and I'm about to begin yeah
it's kind of crazy because I was
thinking about it yesterday and I said
right now I'm on a whole different level
I just got right here okay King of the
statues they get the best I think less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved Laura King how are we doing sir
I'm doing fantastic not as good yeah
I'm terrified
everybody that was looking for combat
talk yesterday that wasn't gonna happen
um but Vol did his thing but attic did
his thing better so uh shout out to the
ball go beat up Canelo again and we can
just close the chapter on that door but
um what I've been playing uh ghost song
okay okay and I did that yesterday today
when we was in um what's the name yeah
so so
I was telling Sovereign about it and I
said when I get home I'm gonna check it
and it's a little icon next to it it was
like yo try it right now on your phone
so I didn't have no Wi-fi no water I
just went off for data um I was right
there while I was eating I was just let
me let me partake I just wanted to
partake and uh he he watched me partake
can't do that on those other flowers
the switch is outside
in the realm of the Lord's not telling
what you want to hear but
you hear yo shout out to everybody that
pulled up player 1C let's give them some
love you know what I'm saying yeah
shout out to Anubis that pulled up in
real life you know what I'm saying also
a lot of people were asking for it
let me tell you something
decision
executive decision not too much game for
me I mean shout out to all my boys CJ so
double what he's doing on the dmeal
joint and um we did Roots of evil that's
a dungeon I never beat and he was doing
it old style and you was doing a new
style yeah yeah
you know how I beat that one I had two I
had two cards one to get us all together
and then I teleported right out of the
ball then we just hit him like crazy yo
he's you got yeah what I realized you
gotta jump them to get the armor down
but the thing is you got to get the
other boss to check out first that makes
it rain automatically
I can't remember we but I think they
might have been close together and we
had a bunch of AOE attacks yeah because
what we did is we focused on how we got
her audited that I had the ball and I
had everybody protected and then what's
happening is he's putting up too many
roots and then we lost one person so
it's just me and him and then we ran to
the other side of the map got a got a
card for the chest and then lured him in
and then we just choked them at the end
but yeah he'll graduate is crazy shout
out to people
they're eventually gonna do a PVP thing
yeah I want us versus them yeah that
would be crazy so I can officially say I
beat the developer yeah carrying me yes
it's something that once you start it's
gonna be innate to you yeah it is
nothing doing dungeon and Dragons you
get the card system basically and that's
your turn but then each character has
their own abilities with each cards that
they have right and then you have an
intrinsic card right that you could
always use but they usually like walking
down that's where I first have been like
was it because that frees you in place
assassin
you dip around that type of stuff and
then the guardian he could arm her up
you know what I'm saying to get like
he's like the tank character that's
that's that's right and they just kept
attacking him and I go in front yeah
right yeah I normally the Assassin like
so you'd be the aggro guys yeah and then
it's actually going to move around yeah
see what you do is you go invisible you
Scout you find out where all the The
Kinks in their armor are then you come
back and like I have like a moves like
teleport behind them I do
active snitch
no but but you know what you know you
know how I report too yeah
these may not be in order
as I see here
um I Hope they've update it but we got
to start it off free R Kelly and the
[ __ ] yeah
Ragnarok he's gonna be playing in secret
talking about the game with whack in
public it's okay I feel like I feel like
if it was just thinking
the dumbest thing chaos about you is
you think I'm gonna be ashamed to play a
game like I'm not gonna tell you I
played it before you the Super Fan like
you don't think I'm a rival in the fact
that at least 80 percent of you guys is
gonna be playing it on PlayStation 4.
and I'm gonna do 20 that's gonna be
playing on Playstation 5. you ain't
playing it at all you're in jail
you only kiss like 30 minutes on
computer time
R Kelly must have had a visit from
police
all the time
you got to get hers
then we got flame five dollars
everything I do about IOP was alive this
is the first show where the title says
it's live was every other show
pre-recorded with elaborate and the
editing you're just a perfect editor I'm
gonna editing not that good
we are Kelly once again
oh yeah the Jackman no no
to play yeah you're feeling good because
God of one came out yeah medicated he's
feeling good
feeling good because he got a game to
play because his PlayStation been dead
for months
that we have no space 23
yeah
why twenty dollar Super Chat please man
dingo big dick is got a war Ragnarok has
a lot of Graphics option and is a
Crosstown game that looks better than
any Xbox next gen game releasing next
year
I understand
now I'm I'm saying that one
okay I'm getting that one to myself
because I understand you're suffering
with something but you're nice though
thank you I appreciate it if you think
so time then we got free on Kelly twenty
dollars
he ain't gonna eat ramen noodles
it's over Sony dominated Xbox Halo is
dead you're console ain't selling like
PS5 gym Thanos Ryan destroyed the Call
of Duty deal even if Phil couldn't stop
it gotta War Ragnarok is a 10 out of 10
and it ain't on game passes
you're the only person who dominated
and you did 20 for this it's Kels pick
your battles
oh you're playing on PlayStation 4
anyway I know you guys
build a taco two dollar Super Chat even
live sub is still late
our fantastic
apparently though
we got bad dick going big things
period right okay what did little man do
today
how come y'all can't get the 4K 60. and
it ain't real 4K you're doing this boy
Dynamic yeah
Kelly went to get two dollars
I'm waiting for you yo it is
a little bit different
he's feeling good today he's feeling
good today hold on a second then we got
that we got that
Macho Man
this will be an epic show for the ages
as sad as me this will be the last time
King has his knees till evil Lord
addicts well that attic has my knees and
they grew back already as you can see my
knees are said but I haven't got my
knees last week tell me you don't watch
the show but without telling me you
don't watch it
now this is the thing
it's not update you have to just
just okay so just reload it yeah gotcha
see that's what happens when it's live
live
if you guys want to be you're generous
and I appreciate that
um let me see what we got we got Neo
mental
all together like bulge hold on it's
like and I have to open the whole thing
[Music]
I'm done with this arguing over the
pizza thing I've never had New York
Pizza I gotta at least eat the New York
pizza that's right we don't do no
designs
we'll do cake pizza
then we got her mom with I guess it's 40
rupees I I think I'm not sure
um absolute master class from the ball
made it look easy yeah like that that is
no lie yeah I mean before I thought it
was going to be I thought Ramirez was
going to give him a hard fight
he has good timing and and speed timing
beat speed it beats power the ball is
really good
this is okay
I'm gonna try to catch whatever's coming
in line because it just really you guys
are too much right now I think no I
think we're kind of good though
I missed something I apologize I will
run back right now yeah you guys are
about to
now
so God of War right what's up up first
and Better Credit really strong looking
like 94 right on on metacritically it's
for PS5 but I know King has some things
he wanted to say in reference to a
reference to developer comments and
pushing like the maximum amount of the
port you know so so king um where are
you at with uh developers kind of
stating that um this is like a a Max
setting PS4 game push to the limits on
PS5 not to take advantage of the hallway
oh yeah
that's impossible you're talking out of
both sides of your mouth okay you're
saying that you got parody with the
PlayStation 4. put your maxing out over
here on the PlayStation which is a lot
so then then okay so if that's true so
then your max is 4K 30.
Dynamic 4K 30. right that that's the
that's the match right we're good so
this is what you said
I thought the machine what happened to
the SSD
I mean what happened I thought I thought
people said that SSD was gonna boost the
graphics I thought 4K 60 was this is the
future yeah
what happened to Generations
so right now the PlayStation 4 is
holding us back because we can't get all
we can't be all we can be right we got
to be limited in some form of fashion
because it really can't truly outperform
the PlayStation 4 version because then
it makes the PlayStation 4 version
obsolete so you have to have some form
of parody so again who's holding who
battle so this this is really the series
that sled this is we back again to the
Crux of the Crux of the issue which is
when people were saying the graphics
artists were saying that um oh he failed
at the series that was the issue and
then something called it was a statement
it's deleted or something like that yeah
he wouldn't die yeah once once Big Chief
woke up I mean the Twitter came for him
yeah yeah and it was because again it
was an opinion that he's had before on
Twitter right right and a lot of people
have come back you know pushed back on
it like okay we're still in a position
where there's a lot of cross gen games
so the albatross can't be the S period
right where we always talk about how
these people built the least common
denominator fine that's always the case
but that's the reality of the business
like you can't call it an albatross if
that is the business of games this is
the least common denomination
are you good
okay
the thing for me is this right I've
always when it comes to
cross-platform stuff I'm like that's
game that's this game development right
it's just I don't it doesn't bother me
that you know it's it's cross-platform
and it's not the other I can see in a
closed ecosystem like a Playstation Xbox
or whatever or a switch
you have to if you want to keep
something in the family that's what's
going to happen right that's absolutely
but at the same time you do give
yourself that advantage of being able to
to especially a first party Studio
develop to the core down to the guts of
the machine you understand that you had
the machine before anybody else you
should be able to maximize the potential
of that machine right
when you're staying between two
different platforms money-wise I 100
understand it was PlayStation 450
million place these are basically PS4s
right You're Gonna Keep building for
that um
now for the person who got the PS5 moved
on from the PS4 and they hear the devs
because this is not so this is not
conjecture from a Dev from outside this
is not an art Direction
whatever department but it is always
Santa Monica oh so he actually worked on
set games yes yes okay so so what did
the other guy work on he was working at
um
so you know for you to be like hey we
built we built this out to take full
advantage
and PS4 Pro right and so we've maxed it
out on that right
and when you come up what's on the Max
on that though it's like 1080p 1080
something disgusting something I heard I
appreciate the graphics options I
appreciate the performance options I
appreciate that 100
but when you come out and say that
it just for people who are paying
attention to the narrative like us
it doesn't sound too good what does it
sound because now you're saying okay we
maxed it out on this machine when you
play it on the superior machine you're
going to get inherent benefits just
because of the power of the machine
right so it's going to be smoother it's
going to look a little crisper whatever
but it wasn't built to the specs of that
machine and taking it back so do with
three we're almost three years into the
life cycle of these new machines right
you know
I get it like I get it I'm just excited
for the game I'm not gonna worry about
it once the game is playing in my house
I don't really care yeah but these are
things like when we have these arguments
about
you know
graphic settings and just that
performance
understand that the business supersedes
everything exactly and the business will
continue to I don't see them Herbert
Hall said it too yeah he said it's
moment
I love her Herman said it there's going
to be plenty of games more than you
expect that are still going to be back
that's what I mean her like this
you know so theoretically that the PS4
would be the same equivalent of the
series just in terms of because of the
basis you know people are supporting
that's where the numbers are well yeah
some of these foreign
suits don't care about performance they
care about this before nobody care about
so that is going to continue to happen
and other is as PlayStation 5S become
more available right number three years
right aren't they still selling
PlayStation 4 right take that thing off
the damn shelf so you can sell them
they're not gonna do that right so who's
really holding back Jim doing it on
purpose
you say Jim is doing that on purpose
yeah I'm good you good yeah I agree what
you think
it's crazy that he won yeah
it's got one question does it run good
is it 60 frames yes
come
don't get magnifying glass to the screen
you know the difference when you see 4K
you play on your big faith I played a
monitor I don't care this is true yeah
they just got 14 40 people see I I I
what I'm the one that reviews the games
I can't play on this fantastic stuff
do the editing yeah it doesn't matter
even if I play it on the screen it
doesn't matter okay I got a question
yeah because you just said it doesn't
matter right
the thing about it is this and that's
right it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter right no because they're
marketing it to you I'm not the priority
right you are right it's in style based
though right
oh yeah I want to see how much they sell
no I'm going to say because again going
back to the king's talking about the
topic like what do you feel that them
continuing to support the PS4 as a
result where some people may say hey
they want they don't like to developer
that's necessarily stating yo we
couldn't we didn't push the limit yet
because of the PS4 like it's basically
if you look at the digital Foundry um
comparisons they kind of say like it's
it's the stability that you get take
advantage of at PS5 like it just
maintains that frame rate and stuff like
that so what do you say for the people
who are like hey baby frustrated they
want it to go to the next level because
of the PS4 as long as that PS4 is part
of the beginning of the development
cycle they'll always be held back yeah
it's just like with the Xbox series
that's acts like they can use both of
the consoles but as long as that s has
to be considered while developing the X
will never be able to do exactly what it
needs to do it's just like look like
it's just the pro we've always lived in
this world even back with the Xbox One X
and the Xbox One S the PS4 the PS5 the
PS4 Pro and we get too many of these
things yeah man the majority of these
third parties have PC iterations with
like 30 different cards like this has
always been the case for everything you
know when you develop for one skill it
just
to broaden that Horizon just money how
many more people can we hire to work on
this port can we hire an entire other
Studio to work on this port it's just
it's been the process for everything
it's just right now usually console
manufacturers never really cared about
the PC portion but now there's treating
these consoles like cards are treated in
the PC got this you got that you have to
make for this it's just like at the end
of the day
if you don't like it don't play it
uh I think you know especially with
seeing God of War reviews they're
they're selling really well so at the
end of the day doesn't matter they oh my
thing is I know the the reviewing not in
New York
okay okay
see the thing the problem is is like you
don't need to take over there right no
no you throwing the words out there
right and you're saying they're
reviewing well
and I got a question for that but I'll
wait till you finish I feel like
as long as they give you the option to
have a 60 frame that you can take a hit
with the resolution like golf tonight
it's out like I might as well throw that
golf knife out that window but like it's
not happening
place tell out the window like it's not
happening but if you give me the option
of like look I don't care a whole
entirely about that resolution you can
bring that down and just let me play it
at 60. that's important to me right and
as long as they give me the option I'm
not going to go into the other
performance modes because I know which
one I'm playing on I gotta save the
attic right you completely too right
here on this laptop
PC gameplay
when it comes to gaming throw it out
no I don't know
I'm not about that you know what I've
already I'm not going on a rant all
right
no contention with these fake ass these
fake scores right well I gotta be
effective I don't know why you know why
okay you know why because there's an
outlier out there okay so so who's our
lives career
they got it right everybody else got a
room okay so so you said everyone else
is paid
integrity yeah
that everybody was paid off it was North
Korea too
I just said you're getting this Korea
wasn't afraid oh like you know you got a
bunch of dudes there
it is good to stay in a group right so
when they start shooting off them shots
you know what I'm saying you might not
get hit so when you're standing in the
front right right well like Korea did
career was like yo that game is boo-boo
Korea was like yeah it ain't what
they're saying it's like you got all
these outlets and everyone's like yeah
this is good and they're crazy like that
ain't it yeah
I already know what happened they got
they accidentally got the 2018 version
I like your career yeah for standing up
and standing on your Square that's right
don't fall like you're the only one
standing for what's right
I'm like I hate finding one review
like okay this is cool that's not what I
came here for the world right now
I don't know I said Korea say what I'm
working I'm just standing on these clear
yo that's right
that's my thing I think it's kind of
what you said so I think it's just that
this generation is just gonna go so much
longer than we expect with the chip
shortage everything that's going on the
the scarcity of PS5 the economics of it
you don't need to raise obviously raise
the prices up in certain ranges that's
crazy so I think right now this is
something we're gonna have to get used
to for a little bit longer we thought at
this point in the gym it's gonna be next
gen only PS5 only series X only that
kind of stuff and I think it's just
gonna be a little longer so look Finance
best like you said Herm is on his
business it's too many PS4s out here for
them to ignore that demographic and at
the end of the day this is their big
money time this is the one they expected
a lot of revenue from highly acclaimed
happy 40.
so that's just like what they they they
have to chips is in the chips and it was
always going to be the case because once
you remember when you look at the sell
process of PS3 that gives a lot of stuff
because it was just hard for people to
program right even if you work on a Sony
first party it was hard to program
forward so the thing is once PS4 was
basically off the shelf parts and
basically a PC
or you knew this was gonna happen
because like Alex said
all of these are just different skus of
a graphics card essentially right of of
systems basically so moving forward you
can see a lot I would not be surprised
they they keep trying to just keep
people at Bay like yeah a little bit
longer no
I guarantee you in two years there will
be games that are still on board so you
think we're getting another two joints
yes
at the moment they decided to make
inflation and Xbox
show Parts essentially mini PCS
apart from apart from somebody else
but the system they built on a chip
system on a trip is the bespoke park
right because but all of that is is a
GPU that's comparable to xgpu on the
market right a CPU is comparable to xcp
on the market it isn't anything like I
said there's no processors dude oh
exactly yeah the only thing bespoke
about them then he's gone I'm not gonna
say anything I didn't see nothing I
didn't see it doing anything yet yeah so
this is the thing two more years so they
can they keep thinking people aren't
paying attention to this but you need to
pay attention to this because don't be
disappointed when in two years in some
first party game is going to be
cross-gen as well because it's just what
it is it the PS4 is just a weaker PC
that they can continue to spec towards
it doesn't make any sense
we gotta be real here though this is the
PlayStation problem this is an Xbox one
problem right you they've already stated
that a vowel to be a next-gen only
they've said foreign
that he thinks that Spider-Man and um
[Music]
yes it is it's
2020.00
this is actually the thing about it
didn't they release uh miles on the the
PlayStation yeah and did they go back
and release it on PlayStation 4
and then retroactively like six months
it came out on the PlayStation 4. I
don't know tell me who it is so just to
clarify you really I just come back from
my knees like Jason
I'll give you the knees
you could ever go back regularly I'm
coming to West Virginia
I just personally feel like there's a
reason
do you guys honestly believe
Spider-Man's coming out next year well
you really believe it we had we had the
last of us delay delay right we had all
these games and keep in mind Spider-Man
has been like actively development
during the middle of the pandemic yeah
you really think that the same company
that came out and said God of war is
coming out and told it last year knowing
they were going to delay it with no
gameplay just a CGI thing you think
that's gonna be out next year
I think I think they
Spiderman this this coming year I didn't
say 2025 for Wolverines so they've
already given them something two years
anyway I I think Spiderman what I'm
gonna need the chat to do is put a one
in the challenge in 2023 and put it
doesn't matter what you think
they said that title that he talked
about that came back that was initially
touted as a PS5 exclusive and then went
to PS4 it was God for God yeah
I like that but we brought we got the
Premium Edition
I don't know what to say I'm just proud
of y'all keep playing the blueprint for
the future and remember heart mind body
and soul balance you will never go wrong
things
yeah
sea cows that's how you do it
live from New York the Lord's all hell
the io piece of little things
it's a tough pill to swallow but
developers need to solely focus on PS5
games the PS5 is two years old and six
you know what I agree I agree with you
CJ
yeah
as Gamers we wanted we want the tech to
be pushed to the next level but the
business is the business and it's still
that installment until that PS5 install
base starts to catch up then we'll start
to see just go out and buy more
PlayStation five and stop telling me
they don't got them available stockx got
them right now
you see how I'm resting right
shout out to everybody that purchased
one and shout out to everybody that is
going to purchase one who wants to do
another live stream again I'm not
talking about live is this I'm talking
about gameplay street so you guys can
join in with us immediatic working out
the Kingston now cool I gotta finish eat
easy uh Super Chat he said I can't I'm
looking forward to see those knees just
make sure they look nice for us King we
may never get this chance again much
love
his knees
he looking fresh out the shower
this is
you're stupid
has a 60 and a 120 FPS option native 4K
30 performance mode is 1800 people
approximately 4K 16. yes native 4K 40
FPS 1440 p.m.
is options this should be a thing for
every game releasing if you want to
watch this watch this y'all don't like
options y'all like to be told what to do
because if you're like options you being
Game Pass cut it out
okay don't come for me
thank you thank you though
[Music]
is there no faith that game will sell
like Eldon ring did it never reached
those numbers come on man yeah casual
Grandma's talking about whoa what's this
album
I say PlayStation is doing their best
like New York is Ragnarok
they're selling it to the same people
ain't nobody buying that game I'm buying
it and everybody that played the other
ones buying it right right okay you
probably get what probably what a
million you're not gonna get the Casual
the same way that Call of Duty is gonna
get the cat call their money spent yeah
as a design guys go we'll see they're
trying they're really trying to I want
to see the numbers against Call of Duty
yeah
the multiplayer yeah so we then then so
do we have it in criteria that it goes
up against the PlayStation that's crazy
King lost his stance when he could
attack it from a review now we go
straight to muddy one okay I can't hit
you from for reviews but you know what
what you gonna sell and he's comparing
it to a multi-plat named Elder no I'm
not comparing it to anything y'all
brought up Elder right well I'm just
saying I don't that's the bigger
question I don't think it's gonna sell
as much as uh 2018 did I think it's a
bigger questions forever it's what 20
million copies now yeah I think Benji
had put something else
is like we dudes be running and they'd
be like yo this dude is projected to win
and then he go home to lose him I think
I think that's the bigger question
yeah
we already know vampire survivors
oh man we're gonna act like we don't we
don't see dudes openly on the platform
you sound like you're applying yes I say
it every year every year is a is an
active buyers that an individual owns a
platform and the individual's interests
no because I want to go to the show
he gives a wink
I don't care you buy me I'll be there
I ain't saying no
PS5 sales are starting to increase but
you still don't see them in stores
they're trying to maximize profits by
selling direct only as a strategy that
is true
things is moving in the street but
nobody see them moving no but I will say
this though when you
we got review scores for Ragnarok but I
bet it's going to be months and months
with no sales numbers being reported on
just like Horizon
ketchup then we got hargit to me five
dollars absolute to the Lords are we
doing a Halo Community gaming session
again a winter update coming in two days
let's go I don't know we don't like
those glitches we're looking at Call of
Duty no we're not
we're definitely not looking to call
that's out the window
playing Call of Duty I ain't playing
Call of Duty if I can sit there and play
Four Guys and I can sit there and play
Candy Crush
whatever Cooking Mama
like everything mom's going to play we
gotta play and I said let's play some
Call of Duty I'm shooting them up bang
bang Jordan everybody playing 800
everybody every the world is playing it
yeah
what's up with that I ain't playing Call
of Duty
yeah
[Music]
here we go move it on all right all
right we got long and peon remember for
two months Ragnarok looks to be lit but
Elden ring still has that game of the
year a lot anyways great work keep up
with the great work Lords and long live
the iops it's gonna be a good fight
though yeah
we got Tony Bryant remember for 28
months after you sir once again happy to
be here live King did you really lose
your knees on as DM basically called God
of War Ragnarok unabashedly a PS4 game
once again great time to be a game I
can't I can't answer that for you Tony
yeah
come on
yeah
there you have there we have Metro night
five dollar super Champion Messi what
options do you have in Game Pass just
asking for a friend that's actually a
bunch of good games I beat them
this is what options do we have again
Whitetail comes out why do I have to do
like print them it's gonna break really
highly
shout out to the Lord's off topic but I
just need to put this out there while
Sony is out there snitching on Microsoft
about the ABK deal they better be they
better take care and not get their own
Acquisitions retroactively Unwound by
the FTC and the EU
a lot of stuff is like that was awful
lot like almost like a letter to a tape
let's be real quick let's be 100 they
can't afford nothing to get the
attention of a uh okay
but we definitely know that the they
have to look what they think whole
company is holding Microsoft up from
doing other things
yes yes yes
I did he gave a five dollar Super Chat
PS has already artificially boosted God
of War numbers with bundles so they can
pretend that they beat Elden ring but we
all know what really happened this is
true but they all do it yeah
there's a lot of things going on you
know the bracelet has been gobbling up
companies and just getting bigger and
bigger
and uh they decided for a little bit
enough cow enough was enough right and
they uh two of the students they picked
up
um have seen some radical changes one of
them closing the most radical of all
changes being shut down so um you may
recall that embracer picked up from
Square Enix has picked up Square Enix oh
Montreal right GG yeah
you're holding yourself it's not even on
the market yeah
I don't get no Jitters no nothing listen
this is wow this is quite
delicious.com
as you twists the can
it's going crazy
so yeah um so they purchased Square Enix
Montreal and they also also purchased
Idols Montreal right so Square your next
Montreal if you guys don't remember all
the studios uh we're at the studio
that was responsible for the Go Games
Hitman Go Laura Croft goal right here's
X go uh very well received games right
so they were more focused on sort of
mobile stuff they
a couple of months ago they had them
Rebrand rebranded
yeah
and they branded so you thought they
were going to take them in another
Direction the direction they were going
to take them is right out the door
they didn't want to go that route they
shut the studio down after having it be
rebranded they took some of the staff
and some of the talent and they pushed
them towards IRAs Montreal now I just
Montreal if you guys know for the guys
who were making Deus Ex right you know I
got clowned on 10 away from Sunday for
mispronouncing their name in my video
like they were people doing
pronunciation
what was you saying what was you saying
I'm not saying the thing is I'm not
opening that door so everybody
over there people anyway before I'm
going to butcher this anyway you say it
man and why they bothering me but I
ain't doing it this time okay we got
time go go go ahead so
the second part of this is that now
Ida's Montreal
is uh they've had some of their stuff
scale back apparently had a couple of
things going on right now right the game
that was supposed to be what they call
the kids on the bike game that was more
right
yeah I don't know what that was going to
be but that's gone horrible and it feels
like they now they've said whatever else
they're working on has been scaled back
in addition to the fact that they're
also working on Deus Ex game so I don't
know if it is that game per se has been
scaled back I don't know what that is
um what's interesting about all of this
and we as we said a few minutes ago is
that one of the games that this newly
kind of reforgas Montreal is working on
is a partnership with Xbox to work on
Fable oh wow much like Crystal D yeah it
would Perfect Dark this is a main line
so this is a Mainline game and again
this is something
I never call it a conspiracy theory but
theories out
seem to indicate that
either a deal has already been made for
Microsoft to acquire these two uh being
Crystal D and Irish Montreal once all
the avk stuff is cleared out right that
that's one of the conspiracy theories
right or just the fact that these
Partnerships are going to continue
specifically to work on Xbox games
what do y'all think because a lot of
this is very weird in a way that we
haven't seen in the game industry before
we know that multiple teams work on big
Triple A games we know like when you
look at the credits there's always a
whole bunch of teams a lot of times
those are teams that are that are
specifically created to do support work
right you have two teams that are used
to working on Blockbuster Games AAA
games aiding in the development of two
Xbox games
I'm just saying like they're playing the
game
what do y'all think again
some conspiracy theories that could be
true
I'm never the conservative person right
and I think this looks a little bit
weird
so that's awesome
conspiracy theories
um it depends are you trying to make you
to have been the neon
with my knees okay as long as I get out
of the state so what do y'all think of
this because we there's been a lot of
and what's funny is just as if it's true
it's illegal but but I think it's
illegal yeah yeah that's basically you
can't do stuff like that but you can do
stuff like that like that's like a
handshake thing yeah there's no
paperwork so here's the thing when that
Crystal Dynamics thing happened that's
unheard of that does not happen in the
industry like you got IGN people saying
this is unorthodox it this doesn't make
sense
[Music]
then it makes more sense because it's
like okay
they're working on
on Tomb Raider not to uh Tomb Raider in
Perfect Dark and they're working on
doing sex
whatever
and fable
it makes no sense
that one was doing it because it's like
this does it this this doesn't happen
but now you have another company doing
it so it's like unless we believe a
coincidence is that two things are
happening that never happens or they're
just working their own employees in the
future right now right so it's just like
look I think that it's like what
happened it
was like one of those things where it's
like
you saw them putting games in Game Pass
before the deal went through it's like
they were they they were moving pieces
on the other side before it actually
happened they're like look
we we have committed to buying you here
give us do maternal and Game Pass not
long before the deal was made right then
they put everything else a month later
in the game passes long before the deal
was made they're like look we're
interested in buying these companies uh
we I don't know I don't think I don't
think Microsoft got into it before the
deal was made I think Microsoft got into
it after it was like one of those things
it's like we know you don't need this
company it's like we're interested in
these we're not interested in these
everybody she's like okay we'll close
those down
uh and they're going to take a small
investment like you know until we are a
little bit more free to make moves how
about you contract them so we can see if
we can work with them internally because
if you can't work with them
on the standpoint of making our games
how about we contract the studio so we
can see if the studios can even work
together in general and then our Studios
can give us feedback on how they work
and then once our deal is done and we
can actively freely do more stuff which
is buy them all from you that's that's
why I think happened I think that makes
a lot of sense the part I it doesn't
make sense to me is that if that is the
case and Microsoft is looking to go
further into the mobile space why allow
them to shut down a mobile device
because they're getting King why would
they need that they have a key but it's
a good shut them down and they low-key
go behind them and pick up and pick up
uh the employees and send them to King
that's true that's true
that is interesting and then um the
whole shutting down part but I'm curious
here
um
yeah
you know you open my eyes to a lot of
things and I just had to put it in the
street terms so like if the feds is
watching me and my man defense being the
CM yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because I'm
not watching Microsoft right they're
watching the statue right and I can't
get to my bread at the moment right but
I told Saul he'll do me a favor go pick
up some of those things and you know I
like them when I when they gone things
being the Xbox I mean uh braces right
right so so remember what's up man over
at the initiative oh all right so Mr
Gallagher yes she probably started that
whole thing
said Gallagher he is more powerful than
a lot of people giving him credit for it
with all those connections yeah so so
listen
Gallagher is the key to this whole thing
right
he moves a lot of needles so what
Gallagher did was like yo I've been in
war with these dudes
remember when they changed the key card
so a lot of dudes they couldn't get in
the building but Crystal Dynamics came
in with the key cards and they just
walked through swipe swipe got it
together
these [ __ ] you gotta leave
so Microsoft you know Fred's watching
them right now we can't really make no
moves because we hot right now
so soft can move from being embraceable
things he Embrace her so and me and him
got a good relationship right so what I
say is listen I I paid for 10 cents on a
dollar when I get back when I get back
up you bought it for 300 million when
you come back I'll give you six oh I
don't need
those other two uh groups so you can
dissolve those and you know what's funny
they get the what they need and they
don't get the back glass for getting rid
of them right yeah
like we don't care what people think of
us anyway no one who knows we are how
many people got fired you deal with that
yeah but see those those people get
rehired someplace else magically really
quickly right
um if you look King is like higher for
those exact positions right then they
probably got an email yo check this out
it goes right goes right
this is high conspiracy
and Phil got to be watching like why
y'all making up these scenarios
absolutely aren't true
so look at us like we need to really
stop them they saying too much back so
you just gotta really look at it it's
just all the tea leaves flow that way
it's just no paper trail there's no
paper trail when I go to my man I'm like
was sitting on these duties for a minute
and then start to make a change six
months to a year that's like two three
months and now you just get rid of
here's the thing
[Music]
yo what'd you do that for
eign
very very frowned upon there's probably
people in the higher ups that know but
if it's truly going on it's not a lot
like oh no if you're holding companies
like it's
one of those things where it's like
maybe a handful of people actually know
what's going on if it is happening and
the moment they saw that they're like yo
what are you doing that's why everybody
brought this mother yeah and they all
sit there like
sometimes they're at a round table a
bunch of stops it's like Among Us
I'm just through believing that there's
any white knights in this industry it's
just not no I mean
we all know this relationship
there's tons of relationships people
know each other people talk and that was
my mindset
yeah that's my only mindset when the
whole initiative thing happened yeah
right now I'm sitting there and I'm like
okay you had this remember this All-Star
team of developers they hired right
they're the who's who without your own
that [ __ ] is about to be crazy perfect
dog about to be crazy then we hit a
rumbling it whether it be a directional
change or what have you and then all of
a sudden all this Mass accidents so it
looked bad initially but then we're like
oh yeah by the way Christian Academy is
is hired they're going to be working on
the project yeah happen to be you know
past execs that had this great
relationship with Dal Gallagher here
they come in the building so now we get
to this and I'm like all right
at first I might remember when remember
what embracer bought them like yo I was
mad cheap
so we sit there like to myself I'm like
you need to tell me Microsoft couldn't
have afforded that what could have
stopped them from doing that and I'm now
not now
you know yeah interesting is if the
David guy were working with Crystal
Dynamics and then they get hint that
these two companies or three companies
aren't happy where they are and they
would prefer something else and he's
like let me find out what I can do and
then before you know conversations
happen it's like okay how much would you
be willing to sell to uh to buy them
from Square Enix and then we'll come I
wouldn't be surprised if like it was
like a domino effect where it's right
it's like I said they're working
then that conversation leads to more
it's kind of like the Minecraft right it
could be yeah we can't do much right now
but then they're like look they're about
to close us down and then before you
know they're talking to an embrace your
group it's like we need someone else to
hold these people that would make sense
because obviously no one could just buy
them right I'm gonna give you something
more sensitive yeah formal system
everybody here knows about being a
perine worker a scam during uh just
picking line or whatever those guys that
get into the system they're already
working inside the system right right
it's very easy to just turn them into a
full-time employee right opposed to
going through the whole process of
vetting and doing all the stuff you're
already in there doing work they're
ready working at Microsoft now they
think that I go for that does strengthen
your theory is the fact that why do they
have these strong relationships with
like key IP Facebook yeah like I mean I
get like Microsoft has so many students
and you need to tell me like none of the
other Studios could be a support we've
seen Coalition we've seen others do so
why this outside
so it's like at the end of the day it's
like that's the part that has my antenna
up like this relationship right it's a
little too cozy in my opinion okay
oh okay there we go so we already heard
it first so um yeah like uh I will say I
will say it is interesting you know what
I mean and then obviously we got the
shutdown of the studios now you know
we'll see what happens with them
I look man if this does happen this is
very very interesting bro because if
once the activation blizzard closes then
we get to see how much
it sounds for real right and we'll see
imagine if the day it closes like the
next day they're like yeah
it's a perfect guard is concluded then
those are officially announced that they
bought them the most interesting thing I
find is okay I think they'll let them
still make the XX I think that will
still be a studio but I wouldn't be
surprised at gristle Dynamics in the
initiative get merged together if they
buy Crystal Dynamics they were talking
about a lot
like I said I mean again we already hear
about the new Deus exactly right yeah
right that's that's the one thing that
isn't really being
yeah
they wanted to be bigger than cyberport
and you know what's crazy if they buy
them and they own the dxx IP that's
another RPG Microsoft that's another
yeah I think at the end of the day
they're going to pass away any yeah
I'm gonna I I honestly think so
the reason why if that happens the
reason why I'm asking for a month
talking about oh yeah
if they buy scorpionics
you Sony had the opportunity to do
certain things for such a long time
square has been literally they getting
the milk for free from the cow right
we're not buying the cow yeah how many
times you're gonna keep doing that
taking that relationship for granted
right square has been dividing on their
own properties for so long they devalue
uh uh square or west and that whole
division though yeah
for Avengers
all right so now you know now you're
looking at square with the quinine
you're like they're not as strong as
they used to be and they're looking like
they're getting ready to be acquired and
we we as a Gaming Community wanted to be
acquired by someone it only naturally
said but the square they do a lot of
like smaller Publishers like
um I don't think Brave no bravity
defaults in other companies right but
they they do the triangle strategy that
just came out they do uh they do a lot
about Travelers Square
I don't know if it provides the value to
Microsoft well I think it provides the
value to Microsoft I just don't think
Sports is going to sell to them like if
they would buy Square they would not
need to do any more Investments ever
they got the Western they got the
Eastern yeah they'll do stuff to fill in
gaps but I but here's the thing like
it doesn't matter if you want to buy
everything you cannot just make people
sound like
just like they're like look like we
don't need you and you know one would
say that I feel like the cultures is
different too like they would be more
inclined to sell one of their owners
they've worked so hard to remove
themselves from anything that's
westernized yeah that I just really feel
like it doesn't make I think they have a
laugh Microsoft
it would be like 20 30. I think that was
so Capcom was said before score 100 I
think obviously
the highest of them all in percentage I
think is already a done deal
I think I think it's a see when when
Satya said stuff like uh it was about
competition let us have competition the
old boy ready to swing them hands right
I think he literally telling you but so
here's about wobbling right yeah okay
once they buy action like let's get
active once they buy an Activision
then they pick up these other two
Studios three Studios from Embrace sugar
room then they pick up Sega
then I do feel like there's a
consolidation problem like now I do feel
like we are in that area
okay so you're afraid of a monopoly no
that's I'm not afraid of Monopoly and
it's just I do feel like in order to
broaden the horizons on companies people
do need to not all be under the same
umbrella because then you're going to
get that that tunnel vision where
everyone has the same type of things
you know what I feel you I don't want it
to happen if they were ever I think
Twitter
for me but I I wouldn't want Sony to buy
them my thing is I think a relationship
stop stringing her on for so long and
just make it happen true but did it get
in in defense if it is happening
probably right I mean but if it's
happening but I still consider them
getting a sexy fat position right right
still you know get the sheddy way
they're getting really fast they're
doing this and then maybe now they can
present themselves okay what about now
at this evaluation you know what I'm
saying you know they got to get rid of
stuff that's really not making that's
not you know it's crazy we keep saying
this and that one's a 10 seconds
we've been thinking they've been like
cutting the fat to make themselves more
uh appealable to like Sony and it's
actually been tense in the whole time
the only reason why I don't leave those
10 cents are giving money Tessa don't
ever want to uh they don't want to be
sugar daddies
it doesn't matter how much money you're
putting in the fan buyer you could put
you know 10 million in the family has
nothing to them right I would have kept
that a flow
so even they are thinking a little bit
more about do you think it was the
government though because remember the
the Chinese government yeah
like hardcore yeah I feel like if they
wouldn't have done that attention would
have bought more stuff
Microsoft's gonna buy the embroidered no
they're not I think they would have just
gave up embrace your group is a huge
company what about this last thing what
about
status quo what if this is good where
it's at where embrace it says you know
what we have these Studios sitting
around we ain't got nothing for them to
do Xbox gonna give us this brand to just
let us you know what I'm saying
how do we not know
that let's say that the deal was close
to being close you know they're like yo
you know Daryl's talking to people at
mine because clearly people know there's
NBA's but some you I mean I know stuff I
shouldn't knows because literally from
people have no problem breaking it right
it's like yo embracian is about the bias
and then Microsoft like you know had
that that like that backdoor
conversation like you know if you're
gonna buy them you know would they be
for sale in the future
my thing is is
so we flipping houses yeah I think that
is I think yo it you have no thoughts in
getting us and they came out of the blue
with that they did came out and you know
and we agreed that the price was she's
crazy
I think the reason that no one's had
that conversations because they were
owned by Scar Enix it's not very often
that a publisher sells Studios like
check this out
and it was like yo what was that for me
hit that for me and because they like
you
you twerk for me because I can't talk to
this dude so what was the brick for me
and bring that back to me I'll get you
one yeah just go get that for me
yeah get a little more bread like you
said did they not inclined itself look
it's an interesting thing again
before the Fable thing I would still say
it was a coincidence what did you feel
like when you heard yes I wonder here
because you're the favorite because like
when you heard do you think babe was in
trouble
was you surprised
not really because I saw it with perfect
dark I feel like right now they're like
look instead of I think the only reason
that perfect art happened is because I
think that was natural but I feel like
this one with with Fable came from the
deal with perfect dark where it's like
look we don't need this studio we've
done this and you know I do think there
has been talks about buying them after
this Activision done they're like okay I
think the reason the Fable thing
happened is because they needed
infrastructure I think that you know
they want people to come out eventually
right and they're like look let's put
these developers to work that we're
eventually going to own anyway but all
you personal income as a fable fan and
you remember you had a little
reservation not that you were against
playground right but you were like your
car studio right yeah so what do you
feel now to actually feel more
confidence
right because I know that
I want it to be more RPG centered right
and I feel like they'll bring more
immersive because because that's a very
immersive game you know bring more
immersive stuff to the faithful
franchise and it's just like you know
after seeing something like you know
we've seen Studios make different genre
type games I'm trying to get out of that
sense where it's like I think racing to
Fable was the biggest jump I've ever
seen anyone ever did at least people
know first person to Horizon
yeah
like they went from what you know keep
in mind it's another team making it they
hired new people but it's still the same
course still the studio you see
playground games it's like okay you're
making playground it's it's the people
that make pools I get it I get it I'm
glad you said that they did again it
gave me confidence too like it made me
like it made me feel better yo it's not
worse right right because you already
know that uh these guys have the tech
right right so you know the world was
gonna you know the graphics
we just didn't know if it was gonna have
the substance yes no I think that this
this is where the substance comes from I
agree and I'm gonna be honest I thought
playground on their own had it just yeah
because of their attention to detail
right they weren't gonna get this wrong
right I think this is a great move to
speed up that timeline yeah yes
do we know what engine is going to be
running them that is a good question is
it the Force protect the Horizon
Tech right that's crazy though I I know
but I don't know I would tell you you
don't say I'm not putting the dope [ __ ]
here we go
we got JD game with ten dollars with
that just got to say it again so
Regulators can hear
unwind it does not have happened just
happened to Facebook and Nvidia was
blocked they outside waiting for them so
JD saying like anything happening oh
okay oh you you think that deal ain't
happening man listen this the world
would burn so I tell them dudes would
buy everything that's when everything is
shutting down you better let that dealer
yeah you better get out the trap house
there we go
do you think Microsoft is going to pick
up after the ABK deal goes through and
before they gobble up the next publisher
Sega Sega or will it be embracer
like here's the thing embrace your group
owns a lot of stuff but the reason that
they go for these Sega stuff is because
they like the publishing units with the
thing like everything is on now British
group has that but they do a lot of
other stuff that they don't necessarily
need right yeah definitely yeah they're
saying this stuff a lot of it is
self-sufficient you got comic books and
stuff like that right they just got
limited run with the um yeah
as bad as it's gonna sound if Microsoft
bought and brush her if you would see a
huge layover after like yeah
that's something that these companies
look at because it's like that they have
to keep PR in mind you know if we buy
this company what are we going to have
to do that's going to look bad in press
because of this purchase and they're
never going to take that yeah because
you don't want redundancy and titles and
stuff like that all right Infinity I can
see them find starting Infinity though
okay
yeah they just show they can do
Microsoft flights
and you make a playtail you can do
flights on Xbox one yeah we need you we
need you now yeah and they do we know
that machine boy boy that was Cloud over
here
it don't matter
that uh Sega don't have Studios what
what are you talking about you're buying
IPS with Sega Cap Fund or WV would be
your smarter move I like them second
Atlas is on my side that's the studio
[Music]
remember when Halloween superhero game
[Music]
I kept saying
[Music]
not a pillow
talk
oh man
pause
yeah
look at it
we did that okay
hectic world five dollars embrace it
does not have AAA Studios so it makes
sense for Microsoft to buy them later
after the ABK deal
maybe not studious they probably least
stuff though
I don't know I just don't see that
happening
and we got Texas five dollars embrace it
is a holding company holding the bag for
Microsoft
I like it Texas if you think like me
don't [ __ ] up on me
then we got Michael Santiago fine I'm a
little Super Chat what an honor it was
to meet you guys at play NYC this is
Mike from yesterday
it was my second year volunteering and
it all started because of you guys
hashtag and why stand up
he waited for like two hours
I'm sorry all right so what you're gonna
do is you're gonna hit me up then I'm
gonna drive to you no I'm not
[Laughter]
greetings live Lords hello
Daddy's laptop is fast
all the parts Microsoft is doing makes
sense XBox doesn't use as much support
Studios like Sony aside from Halo
so it might be a whole company that gets
acquired five dollar secrets from John
TJ hi guys what's in New York got a two
awesome flight I think you can snitch to
me I keep the secret
flame I got this
here we go where we'll be subdivided
after the avk deal oh this is another
thing we mentioned about Square was it
square is has said they're willing to
sell off pieces of each of their of
their Studios so they're willing to sell
a piece of let's say the studio that
makes Final Fantasy whatever you can
have their one they're willing to have
people invest specifically in certain
Studios they're open and they're like we
can be boss they sound like a tick
tocker some tick-tocks you put a little
bit of money on my bag right here
and Avalanche Studios and focus home
interactive the creative Callisto
programs
nobody's buying project I don't know
what the hell is wrong the crazy part is
I don't want the engine and the rice to
rise yes
the crazy part is if you like read the
those Microsoft's making the game with
all those games yeah Avalanche Studio
they're making uh
um
I don't know about that certain Infinity
they're doing stuff with them like
they're doing a lot of stuff with
Studios they don't know yeah
y'all missing the point don't matter
what Microsoft buy ain't nothing
stopping Sony because Jim is dominating
your wallet Kang he's dominating your
wallet listen here chaos
my wallet don't get dominated
your wallet gets dominated after the
fact you don't even got a wallet you in
jail
go play your bunk house why you keep
making people who's running around
watch yourself
R Kelly he's pretty much saying you
ought to donate bigger if you want a
dominance
I appreciate everything even if you just
[Music]
shout out to you sir
here's some conspiracy theories for you
Microsoft buys a breaker gets a bunch of
support Studios and IP then a comic book
then they buy Netflix
I said to go get that's it then we got
y'all baby
bless up Lords y'all in town I'm about
to hop on the 2 train with the ZaZa
blessings
again fine embracing group is a Long
play that allows that Netflix purchase
to then have one premium IP at like 200
weeks
that's too much yeah they was asked
those studios though
plus all those comic book IP would make
great content movies or TV and that's
another thing I really do think that
moving forward
well it didn't go well but they got a
season two coming so it went well enough
no I'm talking about I was I was told
I'm talking about Transcendent media
um Microsoft did that we opened up the
movie studios
but there was another dude in charge at
that period of time TV TV TV was aware
and somebody else
um measured approach as opposed to like
all aggressive all in I think build your
house first don't stretch yourself too I
agree I agree
you ain't putting no games
Xbox don't mean any more Studios they
were gonna win even before Activision
hashtags I know I feel like they're
definitely not going to win yet I mean I
do feel like they have a way better
chance we just got to see the games that
they produce with what they're doing ABC
okay kills the other competition and he
kills them in terms of monetization well
I I mean it kills the competition in the
form of this
once you remove the barrier of Entry yes
with the Call of Duty listen 800 million
in three days that is not nothing to
play with if that thing gets inside Game
Pass what happened you might as well do
it right you know so
um free R Kelly two dollar Super Chat I
and Lords need to buy Twitter blue for
that check oh oh that's next what's up
as soon as he put the price up I'm blue
how about you girls
that's right so when you tweet at me you
show respect uh
caught up yes sir yeah
you'll have to read all of them to me
because I didn't watch it anymore
yeah pretty much said hey one thing
we've definitely heard loud and clear
it's been too long since we shipped what
people would say is a big first party
game we can have our excuses with Colvin
and other things but in the end I know
people invest in our platform and they
want to have great games when I look at
2023 and there's a great lineup of games
that coming that I'm excited about
getting our first uh real Xbox first
party game out of Bethesda have them
ship with red four and Starfield will be
a lot of fun and then Phil also stated
Xbox was doing a lot more work on PC and
then they would launch a big update for
its Xbox app in a few weeks so this is
the talk that's going on obviously we've
talked at noisy of about 2022 and and
what happened and what didn't happen as
far as first party you know AAA releases
you know this was not what Xbox fans
expect and you know they're looking
forward to to more this drought well and
it's definitely not what I expected I'm
gonna need to see I'm gonna need to see
action behind words I'm tired of words
and so it's like I said when it comes to
the Halo thing like
stay inside and stop making statements
to show me you've been talking a lot
you've been talking for years at this
point so it's just like nah I'm not
about that talking stuff you want to
show me or stop talking stop showing up
to the ball no day like show me what you
talking about don't even jump on them
just be quiet yeah well see he's got it
he's got to do this I mean he but to me
it's just like I don't want to hear
that's why I didn't watch it okay do
what you got to do but I'm not listening
until I see what I need done I feel that
I got a second part to fall over
something
whatever what about this you know Phil
actively coming out and saying you know
that this is Xbox fans expect a certain
type of game a triple A game no
disrespect option we've had grounded you
know saying we've had games have come
out this year that's launching Gamepad
stuff but they're kind of a small
variety right it's always double AC and
stuff like that but you know what do you
think about these statements I mean I
think
they've only it's only been positive
that they come out and admit the things
that they know fans are not are
disappointed with right it you know
we're far past the time we're coming out
there with with these statements that
are just sort of covering up what you're
doing and not letting your fans know
exactly what it is that you're doing
those days are over
saying what they're doing you're just
reaffiring and saying stuff he's already
saying eight different ways right in the
past two years but I never heard him
come out of the same so right directly
that way like one thing we've heard a
lot in clear is that you know we they're
fun today
I've never heard of outright same right
and then
to me that's all the same thing yeah but
it hits different I think I just it hits
different when it comes out and says
so for me like it's the truth it's the
truth it's a little different for me
because I I don't have time to play half
of these games so I'm not sitting there
angry at him this Garfield is not here
because I'm gonna get five hours maybe
for the rest of the population
and they really care about that stuff
and care about the Cadence is what has
been said all I say is this I really do
feel that next year you know we've been
hearing wait till next year wait till
next year I really do feel the 2023. but
we said that last year before we like
the question I mean I can literally go
back and and send you videos of us
saying words
my E3 this year gonna be yeah
I do think the pandemic put a huge
wrench in everyone's thing and I do
think that they're going to have a good
2023 but it's like look we can see stuff
on paper we got to see it executed and I
think the biggest thing is going to
determine there's going to be three High
factors in this one is what star field
does two is what Hellboy does and three
is what we see happen with the
Activision too I think the quality the
quality is going to matter more than
anything else right
talk about the Cadence and the fact that
they came out and said something to the
effect of Life hey uh you know we're
supposed to give you guys every quarter
you know we know we said that
so that Cadence I you have to I think if
once again you kind of stepped on a mini
rig there by just saying that that's
where you wanted to be and that being
the expectation everything has gotten
pushed back hopefully that they've
caught up okay even if they caught up to
the point where they have a six foot
party game ready to go I don't see us
getting six first party games next year
so I know there's been a lot of
conversation around like yo what if you
just get next year or they promised you
this year
here's the thing the reason I say
there's three is I think there has to be
a representation of every Big Move they
make how blames the initial Studio as
they bought I think that's one of the
biggest games I would consider a valve
there but I think Hellboy is going to be
the grind for more intense piece and I
think to a lot of people that's
important right now we got gals like
grounding no you got games like help uh
bleeding edge that came out like people
are starting to put
Xbox with like a cartoon right so I
think hellblade shows we're gonna have a
realistic drive
this game so and then you got uh you
look over and you got star Phil Star
Market I think is what represents the
Bethesda purchase uh it shows that
they're not making that Bethesda is back
on track to where they used to be and it
shows this is what we have in store for
you and then it gives people more
excited for anything that Bethesda
Studios are making especially Elder
Elder Scrolls six and then Activision
you know we got to see exactly is Call
of Duty doing this is Call of Duty doing
that did you guys see how is this going
to integrate her to like you know Game
Pass what's that good are they gonna
just like Valor it where all the
OverWatch characters are in Game Pass
like it's it's just you gotta see you
could go out and buy a hundred different
things we got to see how is it going to
to interest us and I think that's the
big thing right once this deal is we've
been talking about this deal for a year
already right
we need I want to see how it applies to
the real world how what what really does
happen with all this stuff how long are
these contracts in place where we're not
going to get Call of Duty and gamer ads
or for however long all of this stuff is
I think 2023 is when we start to see it
begin to see it
um the quality is going to be a big deal
we're talking about quantity right now
the quality is going to be a big deal
and if Starfield don't get where it's
supposed to absolutely if Forza doesn't
hit where it's supposed to well it's
always good and that's the fours always
hits right
and the other one um uh Red Bull that's
very cool that's the only although the
ones that we don't know about is the
dudes that ain't been outside yet right
but Falls in here
oh I'm gonna tell you this oh I see them
all being 85
because let's keep it a buck they have
this is their first full ring with with
Xbox proper yes arcade no mess I'm still
on a little bit iffy with rainfall like
yeah
I'm more open-minded than I used to be
because I used to be really down on red
fault I do think they've showed me a
little bit more for me to have a little
bit more faith right but I still didn't
see them
for redfall they give me that Stephen
King Vibe and you just the gameplay of
Arcane games are so damn good uh to me
and again I've been forces to show peace
forces you have to come out with fours
and say or it blows correctly anymore
it's got to be that anything bluegrass
does well and he's the best at which is
and you know coming out he knows what to
say just when to say it how to say it
seasoned he's very seasoned he's very
immediately
outside saying that you know he
understands that's what my fans
disappointed with the 2022 offering it's
excited about 2023 but kind of like the
first time he's actually outright saying
that to me
so check it out right we uh we consider
Papa John's as far as Pizza go something
some some people like Papa John's
Domino's
those big ticket items right okay so we
won't we're going to put that as AAA
okay right and
let's let's just say hey
just check it out no I'm talking about
pizza we talk about pizza okay right
let's talk about as far as fast food yo
let me get this Domino's get that to
your house look at that that stick oh
you don't like that let's get Papa
John's right all right you you like the
sauce and you like the jalapeno to get
with you all right so it's a little
premium it's a little different than the
pizza shop on the corner okay all right
local guy all right so little kids we
all in a call we saying yo Phil we want
peace we want Papa John's
well we believe in Generations
right so so Game Pass they're giving you
the regular slices you know I'm saying
just to keep you you know satiated
yeah here you go you know nice stuff
yeah you got this yeah this is
cross-generation stuff we don't believe
in that um
right we this is these are the real
people but these are the real people
that don't believe in Generations all
right I mean that do believe in
Generations don't believe in cross-gen
right Xbox One is dead that's dope
discontinue we finish with that we onto
the series so if you want these next gen
games you gotta wait a little bit hold
tight Papa it's coming but eat this
pizza come across the street real quick
Papa John's is coming next year okay
okay all right so and it's only gonna be
served over here see you dudes
that want their AAA experience and y'all
been bothering Sony and bothering Sony
that's why your God walks crossed yet
that's why it's hampered that's why you
ain't gonna get the best you can get but
next year when Starfield drop right Xbox
one ain't talked you Cloud
all right you want to play it you go in
the clouds
what I'm saying is they still giving us
pizza right right we still eat it okay
we eating good yeah
but we still want that Papa John's now
if that Papa John's come to the house
and they cook right
now I get to I get to go to HR we got a
problem here I'm on the phone right I
don't like how this red fall feeling
right just start feeling hit right right
so I that's why I was telling you the
other day I think next to yourself to be
the greatest year or possibly the most
horrible right because you have two
horrible yeah
but you have two IPS right that are
unproven first time in the world red
ball right yes but the studios behind us
yeah that's what I'm hearing is there's
a good chance that Contraband comes up
next year
what I don't think that's a filler I
meant to say I mean but you know what
I'm saying like that's additives
but this this is the thing
we don't know about them oh no question
no this question
isn't it a possibility that it could hit
wrong like it don't you know there's
always right the only thing that the
chocolate yeah Papa John's when the
local joints are always better and
that's what you eat at
um that's the difference that's the
difference
because you got to be talking about this
pizza right here so why are we talking
about Papa John's when we at the locals
that's what I want to know why I travel
when you talking about Papa John's all
right you know what okay so this is
a Papa John's Pizza is what
24 20 25 26 27 you all right
a pie that's my store is 16 bucks right
cheaper don't tell me what's hot bro and
you going cheaper that's what I'm
talking that's the difference so next
year when the real bangers start to come
out you'll understand what it tastes
like for real because you don't know you
still playing the car
but I'm just saying that I'm saying for
good games to come right and it's only
on this on these consoles that you
talked about y'all wanted this to happen
you gotta wait a second and even though
the pandemic was this way
we don't want to use the exclusives he
said he actually said that no then he's
in there taking lunch for no reason
right right because they they should
have kept his mouth shut off right on
that but I want you to ask because when
it comes to
2023.00
what I'm about to say all right so look
I'm gonna be real I was surprised
because I'm surprised he said he
acknowledged probably like yo this is
not what Xbox friends expect you know
what I'm saying this is at least you're
taking accountability right that's
accountability I'm like okay cool not
but to ask for it you know just like
anything else nobody really want to hear
it necessarily just kind of shows yeah
the big talk is 2022 right what happened
it was supposed to be here they died
here and now these games that were
supposed to move on yeah right that's
supposed to be this year are now move to
next year so this is the big place
started this discussion offline so the
debate is okay so now we're looking at
2023. we assume because the way they set
up E3 they said the Knicks what is it 12
months whatever it is right so June the
June almost right right so we're talking
that these games should come out right
so if let's just say hypothetically red
fall top of the Year first half maybe
what February March whatever you know
I'm saying maybe we don't know when
fours are dropped right okay well Forza
comes in
right but if we have those three games
right and then you say Four's up like
you said right turn 10 and playground
any people we could say we hypothetic
like we could bet on being a quality
gaming with the Xbox ecosystem yeah we
can say it's a force okay right so now
becomes
yeah I'm a I'm a horizon dude but I'm
gonna throw that whole car out but as
far as you know we don't play them as
far as the simulations the simulation
Embrace a guy
like sorry okay like the socks
hit me up bro anyways
if those three are the three
right and let's just say hypothetically
small field needs a little bit more time
that's all Phil is kind of like that
second half there so now you have a year
of those three and maybe whatever that
would be allotted all right well let's
just say let's just say that is the year
the question is is that a w or an L if
it's just those three and nothing we
know Global publishing we know all the
numbers
what I'm talking about is you said 12
months right all right
12 months okay from E3 to next E3 these
games better show up all right I don't
care anymore I don't care about the more
time you get everybody get Crystal D get
the initiative get everybody over here
no you know why why you never should
have told me 12 months you should have
never told me from this is what we're
doing now this is
you know
you know what happened yeah
let's call it let's take it along but
it's the other people's release date on
2020.
never came out to say anything about the
release date yeah
all right check it out okay check it out
it's still falling in 12 months okay
12 months okay so that's it
it better be a joke
no I think the 12 months was designed to
not show fables to not show valves right
to have an excuse for why they're not
dead I think that there is there is a
chance to get that says I believe I
believe a man in his word he has been a
man of his word
for a long time hey but if you get
remember correctly that man never said
that a thief no he didn't but he also
behind the word but I said he was gonna
get a baseball game and he got dead so
but I've been right um I'm gonna rock
with him for 12 months
so according to you 12 months if
Starfield gets delayed and that's a full
game that's an l oh hell
it better come out in June
I don't care about you I don't care
about your Synergy with meeting and
aligning the stars and having this I
don't care about 11 11 23 no June that's
your cutoff date for that day June so
okay hold on okay
let's say it comes out June but it's
buggy comes out in November it's perfect
yes I've been playing both the games
you ain't gonna get him in town with the
most information
star crafting game Space
you know what another one they said they
just needed a little bit more time
then we'll still go by the studio and
it's about Jewel and it's Craig faces
this is when you do this
yeah
yeah
do me a favor
um send the whole initiative over
um
page Coalition
okay your turn turn yes turn ten you
turn into I know playgrounds is doing
what they doing bro this game got to
come out okay okay
so you know what all you just did you
delete all those games
so instead of having one game to like
six six months you just have to put the
rest of the whole life you want every
studio all injected to this check it out
what they shown
[Music]
which is like
they come out right
and then you you get one of them joints
that that wasn't seen maybe that hell
played yeah maybe that'll foul at the
end of the day right at the end after E3
next 12 months the most Monster yeah
right to you if it is redfall Forza and
starford only those three as people say
to me is it a noun might work like I
think as long as star field doesn't
start it's supposed to be it could only
be star Phil because as long as you have
a title that dominates the conversation
on everything else if you have a game of
the year you've won already but if you
have multiple contenders obviously fours
ain't go together because you know how
they feel about racing it's just like in
one day IBM last year
my personal opinion when it comes to it
is
historical needs the time get gifts
they don't get no more time you got your
jewelry
Jones
but if someone came and said yo I know I
said I don't care
don't bring me no bad news
I'm not knock on my door
King but King all right you right y'all
started with the Witch of the West right
what happened she's sending them goons
out when you came with bad news don't
bring me no bad same dudes that be
talking about something
we just came off that kid nobody told
him
they gave me a nice controller uh got
nice controller Halo Halo right let's
that's what I play Halo with you I
support
and I hold you to accountable for your
work so so they said no no no no no no
no
okay so listen they they always want to
switch it up they always want to change
up stuff uh yo what's your numbers we
don't go by that we go by engagement
right so all right so we go by
engagement right we're gonna buy
engagement right all right all right so
y'all engaging crazy that's cool now we
gotta follow engagement right y'all
check y'all go to E3 your change the
format up they ain't showing you nothing
down the road okay next 12 months
next 12 months right
every time you want to switch it up so
it fit you it better fit for you okay
you got to dream okay so let's just say
let's just saying right yeah
right there's a lot of hypothetics
now
was that showing that E3 yes it is it
was right
[Music]
they got some things right they're able
to say we talk about one of them little
secret projects maybe he was at the
contrabands or the whole job okay okay
listen Okay so if a girl tells you'll go
out to date right you'll go out to date
right they're going out right and she
said no I don't want to do nothing right
now right oh she hold it out oh you feel
it right now baby I I don't do I don't
get nothing right now
but but
in four months yeah it's four months
going Freddy if that's my Hardline yeah
you respect that hard line but you were
supporting taking off
doing the fake happy smile things right
now
November for you for four months
they should tell you I'm not ready yet
you got to go it's over the deal is over
you said four months
oh [ __ ] you got 12. see you in June
you got no more to talk about see you in
June and we'll see you again
listen
respect my wife
respect my wallet so if you guys tonight
for a long time respect
for the studio
you don't hear nothing I don't wanna I
don't I don't care who job it is to jump
in there you told me 12 I don't talk
about all the extra all week just got
ABK so we got all I don't care Jason
said while your friends are getting
lucky in the process exactly right
everybody else getting lucky
I'm hitting them
man like again if if this is I'm paying
the scenario if it's only Red Bull
foreign
we didn't get the games before we're
getting them now so somehow they're
devaluated
we getting them later you're getting
them now
keep in mind little stuff like my uh
Minecraft Legends
oh yeah we're getting all that spring
next year
the other one that was like he's running
the 2D joint
s
replaced replacements
11 11 23. that okay
he promised you but I'm gonna tell you
this right now if there's ever a game
that is never finished yeah
bro you don't want that game in June I'm
sorry you don't want it you don't want
to know you don't want to do I want to
say don't don't tell don't give me all
high enough
thank you
12 months right right we go I'm thanking
you too okay 12 months if you're feeling
down 12 months that's the problem all
right I'm gonna do a whole video my own
videos
to me and if it's just those three games
again
in fact I'm not worried about what you
were supposed to have in 2020. I'm not
so so the the argument that hey okay if
it's only those three what did you have
planned for 201
he told me he said yeah because he's
saying that means that you what what do
you have planned for 2023 be that these
games are supposed to come out I feel
like
it's okay to want all four right but I
do feel like it's one of those things
you could never be like it's like Star
filled Forza and red fall and then you
know you got the Age of Empire four you
know on Xbox I feel like that's a solid
you could be greedy and want hell Blade
with it but I feel like it doesn't
necessarily have to they didn't show
hell later yeah
let me ask you this then if you get
those before E3 and you get hellblade
next year in the holidays
I'm the dude in the contract
um if you sign that contract and you say
You're Gonna juggle and spit fire you
know you better juggle and spit fire who
else is breach of contract and then I
want reparations
no I mean to me
to me they hit where they're supposed to
hit that's going to be plenty you can't
accept this and then when you think
about the other stuff they have until
like everybody
concerned when they asked before the
party first party the first party will
come when it's ready I don't want any of
these games coming out undercooked and
then the narrative turns to once again
oh look at these quality mid games look
how they rushed it out
you know what's going on
and I think Halo is an outlier right I
think with so much stuff going on with
that and I'm Ready the perception with
them was a little bit tense so it was
agreements he said every game from my
last summer showcase better be out but
right I'm gonna tell you right now the
majority agreed with kids because they
don't want to hear that no I I've seen
what we want what's realistic but you
saw what they did I eat three though
no more dream into the future
right you're absolutely right and it's
on them all I'm saying is that the
Starfield represents something bigger
bro so like stall field
afternoon let's say let me give you to
another one let me say
they do announce Starfield delayed until
11 11 20 23. you get Forza before E3 you
get redfall they announced a release
date next month and you get that like
February March you get like little games
uh you know sprinkle between but that
June event
they announced Hellboy release date they
announce let's say valve release date
layouts whatever the button the next
holiday game is maybe involved next
holiday and we have a really good
presentation next year that's that's
solid that we all like but star Fitness
delay are you okay with that exchange no
gets delayed to the engine no I'm not
I'm not okay with it because you lied to
me okay
it's a rape they didn't need to step on
that race especially when you include a
game like a BDS game in in in and you
give it any kind of window I've always
felt that that type of game bro
as good as Todd is he's
so this is again I'm talking for those
individuals that don't care about it I
don't care about stuff
to do what they said and if they want us
to fall in line and follow suit like
right in the streets y'all was getting
Molly walked and beat up around when you
wasn't selling the same numbers and
y'all gave me a ammo to yell out and say
engagement yeah you fix it you changed
it right so these dudes had they little
E3 right
future stuff they showed you now stuff
y'all guys said calm down calm down only
12 months right that's it right
this is what's coming out right but then
you got to think about 2023 I told you
that's only half the year yeah right
what are they going to give us after E3
we get another 12 months of fun so
here's the question do they do that 12
months they better don't you change it
up on me I want them to change but I
know he wants to find this guy but
they're gonna show people that [ __ ]
though
if it comes out
next year when it doesn't get delayed
it's made I have a big fan of a game
coming out so close to E3 bro I think
May 15th I'm just saying you want to
give it time because
until the end of the year no matter what
they've said it's like that's that's a
game that you sell uh special edition
consult with yeah or like to me that
feels like a holiday thing yeah so to to
see just because we had to delay it from
its original release date and to be like
okay we're gonna give this to you yeah
they told me you know what the hell is
if they fall out of 20 20. right now
that's when I'm with him if they'd be
like yo it's not coming in 2023 at
January yeah
my thing is this we did not call it act
like Starfield when it hit
but that's the A Team
Zeitgeist
Eldon ring level
what was you doing oh my God it's going
to control the network about Elder
Scrolls in space new IP XBox exclusive
right now we talk about that right
before we be conservative right yeah
let's just say red four in the 80s even
though our latest trailer look really
really good okay
okay right so my thing is okay that's
the question mark we don't know yet it's
okay but it's Arcane new first time out
you know what I mean brand new IP okay
bam Forza we know what Falls are doing
if there's anything it would be the
ultimate banana peel we know they they
slip all they call how far I'll make a
90. let the critical offering anything
they do yeah so starfood is so cool that
you cannot have egg on the faces off it
you cannot have the face of the new
generation of Xbox in their control with
any warts it got to be as clean as
possible so you launched that bad boy
out and here's the thing
I don't blade
blade right y'all doing a lot of trying
to sell me on this wait up for this I'm
not I'll tell you I think it's the
weight is months though it's not like we
telling you to wait years you know our
argument is our argument but to be fair
they have no reason to put dates on this
thing right and that's where I'm with
him I had no reason they had no reason
Ty they had no reason
[Music]
foreign
I think there's a potential you could
get Hellboy next year on the holiday but
even if it doesn't I February March you
know what it is I wasn't really
conditioned though this is the problem
yeah so all the stuff that I saw at E3
and they said 12 months I'm like all
right cool this is what I got this is
what I'm playing with the gunk came out
yeah those stuff came out I was like oh
right then we got that other gun with
the gun game the the guns with the knife
he stabbing man oh you talking about the
Ohio life yeah
right so that stuff is coming up the
stuff that they said is coming it's
gonna hit it right my thing is just
doing 12 months let's just stick to that
I get it but you talk about one of the
most ambitious
what I'm saying is
when they came out and said 12 months
y'all knew them listed again right
before that with Halo they had all the
market they were supposed to ship was
supposed to do this and he was listening
to somebody else that picture will hold
him into a situation where okay now we
got to delay this whatever happened this
got to happen we're gonna eat a ton of
money off of this off the market there
you know and then it still came out with
situations yeah so that led to the
dysfunction of 343 right we don't
believe this dysfunction in Bethesda but
we do know that they delayed up on a
promise that they made with 11 11 that
they couldn't keep so clearly this game
but that was before they got purchased
but they still didn't deliver what they
said they said 11 we kill all and they
were like yo no stars do you think
because of that
because because of that time so no yeah
no I I think I think the 12 months was a
convenient way of only showing the game
to them
but I don't think I don't think maybe
show necessarily knows it's ready to go
I think the 12 months was a direct
feedback thing they're like okay you
want to see gameplay we're going to show
you 12 months because that's all the
gameplay we got over here
there was a games called that I really
like the format they did where they
showed games in the next 12 months for
half of it right and then the other half
was games in the future and the next
year they would just rotate that at the
lighter half to the front half and then
show the new stuff in the background
this is
oh good thank you
I got a candy gamer
it's not TV TV TV you need both
cyberpunk you need both cyberpunk prove
that punctuation people please cyberpunk
proved that cross media is the way to go
you sold Millions more games and that's
why Microsoft will be buying Netflix
plus they're cozy already
yeah
because it to me it's just drawing money
you know what they want though right
they want Netflix so they can roll it
into game passes
hey seriously I gotta ask let's say they
get Square Enix who would be the second
publisher they buy Capcom or all of WB
or Sega then be done with Publishers
and you know what I'm gonna tell you
this if that Sega deal does happen I
think Sarah bond in that deal oh she was
over there yeah I think Sarah you saw
how she looked in that picture yeah
no Capcom is too strong now bro now
Resident Evil has revived yeah
yeah
flame 2000 Super Chat did Matt say Halo
was a failure
yeah he had a statement I'm talking
about like that yeah
like that first party stuff was like a
Rudder and falling at the Finish Line
specifically yeah he's an analogy okay
again very forward well no way dragons
with open arms hope you enjoyed this
city backs our city back so what's up
brother you want to wait chill with us
last night
he's still digesting that food
thanks then we got Tai casares three
dollar Super Chat Hey Arnold what are
your top five game studios
we'll get back to them yeah but we got
you though just reacting
all the Microsoft all the Nintendo all
the Capcom motorcycle
foreign
up I'm excited oh this is the time to
eat yeah
we got Lawrence down we put the crest in
the chapel Lauren Davenport
what's up
and we got brutal Enigma five dollars BS
dudes can't even keep Xbox of Microsoft
name out their mouth now in 2022 can you
imagine the extent of their rants in
2023 when all the bombs dropped
[Music]
comes out after seven years of making it
there's a pro comes out I guess late
yeah there's a problem there there's a
problem there facts What type of game
Cycles are we really looking at here no
excuses put up I mean I think starters I
mean again a bgs game is not a three
four year life cycle game that's just
not like that I will always say right
June is the Beta release date for start
see the problem is this is you're giving
me a title that I'm not endeared to
so if it was something yeah
bring the Starfield over here
we got another woman to see what be you
five dollar Super Chat please donate
your local IOP Nissan to King needs help
getting up
you stupid
I feel I'm the only person alive with
zero worries about Xboxes 2023 pretty
confused at all the hesitation folks
even down Arcane now the read s not
about to reach it's about
people tend to if people can stumble at
the Finish Line they got the games got
to be good they could have stumble we
could just stumble on these super chats
though then we got the little taco
Not only would 2023 be where Xbox
delivers the AAA bangers Game Pass is
just completely stacked with big third
party games just in the first half that
is true as well
all right that's it I think we caught up
there oh they're fun topic psvr too so
yes
see what we use the bed of Beta release
yeah we got that we got that so yeah
launch it officially February 22nd 2023
had the blog post out there showing the
availability the bundles call it a
mountain bundle with it you know what I
mean it closed the storm voucher and um
the exactly the controllers I think I'm
also have a charging station accessory
all that good stuff so yeah pre-orders
are up you can go catch that now if
you're gonna direct them through them
and uh what's the thought process y'all
you don't have the announcement is here
I want to hear candy yeah
I'm sorry like
549 what's the price
so the bundle how much is bundle so you
got to get a game right yeah 600 right
600 for the calling about it did they do
that bottle of funny game like you know
the game you might get it probably a
demo disc that I'm talking about but
yeah that's like just here we're taxing
everything game charging station get to
the point you're looking at 1200 right
what did the boy tell you
what it was gonna cost you to get in
don't tell me please God don't tell me
it only cost 500 no it don't be
because you can't just pick it up and
put it on your face and play without a
PlayStation it reminds me of King it's
like that Thanos he's like what did it
what did it cost you everything
everything
the tech inside is crazy can you just
don't understand
it's disgusting it's absolutely
disgusting and it's old Tech check it
out um
check it out it's old Tech
108 dragons explained to us yesterday
that the eye tracking
has been in cell phones
for 20 years
listen I don't care I'ma have it anyway
I'm the fool that's gonna have the 10
games that is only going to come out
with just like the last one because
there's no cross play what's the best
part about it no back to practice not
even Generations now
550 bucks
that you know they backtracked on the
generations thing for the PlayStation
because they wanted to make sure the PS4
people still had access to the game but
the VR too that did have a whole lot of
install base already they're like yeah
you we just start over starter
okay you know what it is they want to
remake those PSV VR1 games on the VR6
what the key is if they're gonna allow
um like kind of like a credit like say
if you had a version of let's say we
make it
before you fix your face I will say
there's one though that I've confirmed
shout Outcast oil question right now is
called Zenith it's Emma elasticity right
I know you talked about right request
and if you have the psvr one version
they're going to honor the eventual PS
VR 2 and give you can I ask that
question real quick yeah
foreign
version comes out they are giving you
credit credit based on your purchases
okay it's not it's not that they're
upgraded they're not upgrading anything
[Music]
dumb delivery
and they gonna fight this they're gonna
say that we believe in Generations
like they gave you this premium piece a
check or whatever it's a very nice piece
of technical what it is
and in two years is dead yeah they
killed it with the price point they're
gonna kill it with the lack of games
right because you're not gonna get new
games on the list if PlayStation
themselves don't see the numbers out
there which they want at that 550 price
point
gonna be making bespoke games for this
you're gonna be taken
the sloppy seconds off of meadowquest
and off of everything else well they
showed the 11 titles a lot of them
already those titles already for years
some of it some of them yeah
it doesn't make it feels like they went
out and said we're gonna build this
thing to shoot it in the head for
whatever reason
for whatever reason I made no sense to
charge that I think they feel like
people are going to buy it I do I don't
think they put this out there
I think if you're trying to put a new
product on the market and you want it to
sell why is it that their ammo is always
never take the L for so you never take
the L for the Optics never never here's
my thing I personally feel like if they
believed in VR2 like completely they had
to make sure the VR1 was backwards sure
because I feel like you're gonna lose
those some of those people because
they're Gonna Fill away you mean to tell
me that about the same games
like that from a technical standpoint
they've kind of proven that like Xbox
got them ahead of them as far as back
compact they have not proven you mean
this generation that they have every
opportunity when they started yeah they
could make sure it's true and I feel you
but my thing is but look at what PS5 and
the PS4 relationship right now they have
not proven that they have successfully
able to do but it's coming up after the
PS5 so they could have integrated Midway
through development oh okay this is
actually working on Playstation 5.
it's not Forte because I'll tell you
this right now when it comes to that the
PS plus tears and why we're not getting
all these back impact games especially
the really old games they don't want to
give you those games they want to starve
you out until they can say with the
numbers ain't nobody's buying these
games let's eliminate that top tier
everybody go to the middle tier that's
it they they don't want to give you any
of those games so I just don't
understand why do you put all the r d
into this machine
convincing people that they support it
enough because it's important the first
one enough
to bring it because it wholesale really
is who really is if you haven't found a
PS5 yet gonna come out and go get a PS5
it feels like somebody's passion project
I realized I feel like somebody in Sony
was like I don't care I won't be like
you like Jim Ryan Jr
back no doubt right what if it's what
that their base and shoulders the funny
thing is I'm getting it okay so we can
sit
here's that brand recognition some of
those bases what is that the thing is
though
do they want to just shoot where they
were shot right shot before as opposed
to the mask I don't have a VR for a
Playstation did you ever buy it I didn't
get the first one yeah so that's my
point is like from what they're showing
now PlayStation VR ones 25 million so
for more six from that VR standpoint of
you not only According to some
information I found on statista
five million that is the worst ratio in
the business that's that's five percent
oh god of the PS4 installment oh five
percent that's actually what this is
right there you go it's just like look
they're looking to get more people I'm
definitely not buying it especially that
price point off the stuff you now know
you probably buy just because you you
have other reasons why you will probably
but besides that like are they really
getting more people right you talk about
that new audience
made that point too because he he's
disappointed and he was just like
because he believes in VR so much and
he's disappointed they're stagnating
it's forward progress right because if
anybody could help look obviously
clearly I'm with the whole team but
clearly if anybody could help also bring
it to the masses right these these
tremendous
I feel like Quest helped make it more
mainstream right PlayStation needs to
show competition games matter in a
bigger yeah but with that with that
price point I have a feeling they'll
they'll hit the ball real hard for the
first maybe a year maybe two but then
they'll start to slow back the budgeting
like it's not selling them we're getting
a small experiences you're not gonna get
because even the people
medical applications and stuff like that
right so the gaming stuff is even a hard
sell as it is so if they would have came
out and they said it's backwards
compatible yeah and then they do some
restructure to make it work better than
the you know limitations they have on
the other one there's some really
popular ones that's on VR1 they made
sequels to those with better technology
than they have in the original one they
had it at a Sony took a slight loss to
make it at a reasonable price they show
up the game then what do you have you
have you have met up like oh we got to
compete so let's let's let's build up
our stuff let's make better VR games
let's compete with them and then they do
something and then a couple years from
now Sony has like oh they stepping they
stuff up could have had building blocks
now right now we have just Sony
literally pushing their own building
yeah it's only literally it came in with
the Wrecking Ball I'm Gonna Knock it all
down
claim and I gave you buying consoles
definitely just told me everything I
needed to know y'all not buying a damn
thing y'all just capping on Twitter
talking about oh when someone says psvr2
is still tethered yeah
you thought it was going to be Wireless
right you thought that it was going to
be its own machine with that for 550 the
same price as the place
if the PlayStation 5 is its own machine
yeah they don't need me that's what I
mean okay oh sorry I was gonna say not
to mention it's no compatible PC right
right because theoretically if you buy
it off the shelf you right it's this
it's you you can't do anything with it
so you you are required to have a
PlayStation and that's something that
Kings always kind of made up you know
made a point of my thing is and I'll be
honest obviously that's whole team but
the tether thing is always going to be
an issue for me so now I'm going to be
Tethered to you know PlayStation now now
you got a high-end joint that's not
tether that's not tender right so that's
the thing so again we got to see the
adoption rate my main thing was okay the
commitment to the games I do like that
they have a solid launch lineup for the
most part of games available they want
to have like 11 or whatever experiences
yes I know a lot of them have been out
already and none of them are named
Half-Life that surprised me I thought
they have like Alex was something they
could have potentially pursued
I do like that DB
s
but that that's just putting a bag down
that's not investing right now
is a small Studio to get something like
Alex they have to work with them
and I feel like Sony doesn't I'm sorry
they believe in their product it would
be on them
because if they don't play like your
premium demio and it plays like my Dino
right that's when you have a huge issue
the things I've heard about people say
about Call of the mountain that it had
played Alex they say it has Alex
we'll see maybe it is that but what
happens yeah the hope is that that is a
killer app the thing is if you are such
an infant stages still I mean they've
done better to get a little bit out of
the emphasages but unless that whole
industry works together it's never going
to get out of that eventually it's going
to get to a peak and then it's going to
get hit back down again it is such it is
it is still so much of this emphasis
that true competition in the space is
only perfect it's hurting it in the
sense that they're not working together
right they're they're working against
each other and if one has more success
than the other one you're going to start
seeing the Baseline being oh well 20 to
30 minute experiences is what it sells
no more big budget games it's only
looking at that like okay we're not
making any more cold on the mountains
right we're making these 20 to 30 minute
experiences and not what I think would
respond for them is to tie their games
to their big IPS what they're doing and
you know they're doing Horizon and they
do that and I think they can have
success I think that to me that the war
front now they're out obviously I
actually haven't I disagree with that we
got you know what the title today yes I
don't mind if they've tied to their big
IPS it's just I feel like they tried
that with the Vita making their IPs into
and they didn't do nothing when it comes
to the Vita the stories of Nintendo so
you have to make IPS that work well with
that type of planes yeah right so you
want uip so it's like a new IPS like you
have to play something that makes sense
to put your head on you have to play
something
associated with the big game well don't
if they do do what they need to do more
of like you know God of War with the
battle and stuff
I'm talking about not making you know
lag or Rock oh no yeah not saying okay
if you play all of Ragnarok because it's
not it's not forbidden westerns
yeah experience
yeah I've said it it's the open I'll say
it over and over again either these VR
companies need to be reaching out to
these car companies
yeah you make these like imagine like
playing these games and summoning these
creatures in these cards like right
there
yeah
Christopher hardest thing to Half-Life
Alex psvr 2 News was leaked a couple of
weeks ago and it is a trusted Source
shut up Chris
you're the only one Captain you wanted a
five million just like me
oh yeah yeah I want to say is the
landscape is going to be interested in
that area in the space
with the rulers you know our apples
coming yep you know what I'm saying and
there is they have that market value
they have that name recognition of oil
base we gotta see how serious they are
in terms of um the gaming aspect and
then obviously there's another device
that might not be commercial
so let's see what happens with that on
your medicine but
oh we made it
let's go Jackson
[Music]
digital camera have I have eye tracking
and anyway tell the taco five dollar
Super Chat can't wait to see Cog in my
hometown Houston next year I'm a brand
new and Maddie some real mac and cheese
of course ah for the culture for the
culture I'll be up in here February
there we go once again five dollar Super
Chat psbr two cappers let's see how many
of you get it at that premium price I
will have it let's see cappers and God
drops what version you got
you know what it is
ah let me see
that's it actually okay
yeah we got it we got it all we did it
man history was made the first time an
IOP live flash you already know my
friends
the first time in the tower
probably on Twitter at Laura IOP uh you
can also find me on a flight going home
tomorrow if I'm about to eat the best
pizza
we might try to do another IOP idea okay
these these things are cheap they salute
everybody's support as well
then yes please I feel like
you know you might have goals or maybe
we can do this like two maybe three
times a year just depending on what's
going on yeah
the Lord's sovereign
[Laughter]
but yet uh it was this is a man I can't
believe we're doing this in NYC look at
this backdrop behind us this is
fantastic man this is what it's about
right obviously the way of the world is
is we can't it would be crazy if this
would be yeah like every single day it's
not maybe one day it will be we'll see
we'll see but I'm just super excited for
this report
yeah everybody was watching us
I'm excited show this coming week
Ragnarok is upon us yes yes I'm excited
to play that I'm excited to play
pentiment yeah I'm excited to play
Summerville there's a lot of stuff
coming down the pipeline Lord attic
we'll we'll be working on a Ragnarok for
uh
yeah
oh never mind oh
yeah
this no not like yeah
okay yeah
yeah and I'm so happy we got to see uh
Black Adam together yes in the fine
dining restaurant
um in the movie theater which was crazy
oh yes and then we went to Florida
uh I said the wrong woman
and they had a fantastic time shout out
to Tim shout out to Waterway Dragon sir
um and for every person that said we
wouldn't make it to where we have
to every person that said video games
was a fad to every individual saying we
were wasting our time actually I love
you yeah peace be with you
know how many goddamn good time
see you next week when I troll you again
yeah it's good to be with my brothers
this is It's history for us this is
history for us
you know so what we did the lord
it's all we want to do you know we do
this for real real a lot of people and
there's no respect any other podcast and
they actually hang out with each other
we actually tell each other and we
actually are friends you know what I'm
saying and that's important so brothers
are here for real so all that other
stuff we don't get into it but at the
end of the day ain't nobody better than
podcast we had the most fun I don't care
nobody said yeah I'm gonna tell you
right now
we got something special yeah
I appreciate y'all appreciate all the
support all the love you know what I'm
saying we'll be back I got a lot of
things
in the near future that's cooking and uh
yeah we can't really show y'all
and you guys know we will be starting
the early prep for uh the Video Game
Awards thing yes we'll be doing that
yeah
we got the crown yellow we gotta beat
songs
me and him won the year before you've
never won
and on that door
and stream is